Is it safe to do your parasite program with kids? I know digestive enzymes and
SBI. Protector okay for them but what about proverma
feuds or the paratocin or the pylora cell. All of those are safe with kids. You
just have to dose them based upon their weight. So let's say you know it says the
adult dose it just pretend three times a day on something. So if you figure the
adult is about 150 pounds. If you have a child that's 50 pounds you only want to
give them one a day. So just dose it down for their size. Those are fine with
kids. Oh of course it depends on what age kid. If you got a two-year-old that
wouldn't do that at all. But if you have like five six seven eight-year-old certainly
you could do that.